i think that this varies more between
individuals than a lot of people assume
and or realize
there was a study by scarpelli that came
out in 2020 the title was muscle
hypertrophy response is affected by
previous resistance training volume in
trained individuals so basically what
they did in this study
is um
they used a within subject design and
they asked people hey what does your
training volume for quads look like
right now
and what they did for one group is they
assigned them a level of quad training
volume that was basically in keeping
with what is typically prescribed for
quad training in the literature i think
it was like 20 to 22 sets per week
something like that um
so it was split into two sessions so it
was basically like 10 11 sets per day uh
and then for the other leg what they did
is they took the subject's reported
baseline training volume and then just
said okay for each one of you you're
just going to increase your baseline
training volume by 20
if someone was only previously doing
five sets of quad training per week
they'd be doing six sets if someone was
previously doing
20 sets of quad training per week they'd
be doing 24 sets if someone was doing 40
sets of quad training per week they'd be
doing 48 sets um so they they just use
the subject's baseline as what they
built on
and what they found is that on average
the
individualized approach so increasing 20
over baseline uh
on average produced statistically
significantly more
quad hypertrophy than the one size fits
all 22 sets per week or 11 sets per
session approach
and also when you dig into this paper
and look at the individual results there
were a lot of subjects who were doing
quite a bit more than
eight than six to eight sets per session
um
who were doing
like way more than what
would be
assumed to be like optimal based on
uh kind of population level data or just
like the the
group level results from studies that
exist so basically the implication
is there were
quite a few people in this study who
were growing more
on way more than
uh 22 sets per week than they were on 22
sets per week suggesting that for those
individuals the optimal per session
volume was quite a bit higher than six
to eight sets per session
um
all of which is to say
you know
any sort of general recommendations like
this you need to you need to
contextualize them uh if you're training
to failure or very close to failure six
to eight sets per muscle group per week
uh or
six to eight sets per muscle group per
session probably a pretty decent
starting point but you need to keep the
details of the sets in mind so if you're
training quite a bit further from
failure it's probably going to be higher
on average and then second remember all
of these recommendations are just
averages to start at to start your
troubleshooting for you
the the per session optimal volume per
muscle group might be quite a bit lower
than that or it might be considerably
higher than that so you look at averages
to kind of start the troubleshooting
process
but
don't
don't don't be disturbed
if your own
experimentation
leads you to something that is
uh kind of kind of far from the average
because there there is a lot of
variability in terms of volume tolerance
between individuals